you have any good memories from working
on the set with Andre the Giant you
already mentioned that I mean yeah Andre
was actually I never worked specifically
with Andre but I got to be around him a
lot and he was just yeah he was some
fabulous guy in fact I do have a great
story about Andre so yeah
uh my daughters at the time were uh
three and a half and two
and I'm heading to England and I had to
be on location so they didn't come with
me in the beginning because we were at a
hotel up in the you know Derbyshire
somewhere and uh and so I said okay I'm
going to I'm going to England and uh I
I'm gonna be and there's a princess in
the movie and I'm assuming they're gonna
go oh really and nothing and and then uh
there's a sword fight and then there's a
giant and as soon as like the word giant
got out of my lips
both of my girls pert up and they
started throwing peppering me with a
question what's the giant like Daddy how
big is he he's as big as a house as big
as a car is he really really big could
he pick you up and squash it with me you
know just kids right so every time now
I'm on location every time I talk to
them they're as soon as I'd say hi
kitties hi baby how are you Daddy loves
you he misses you hi daddy where's the
giant is he as big as a house as big as
a car same thing right so finally they
come to England
and I realize they have to meet Andre
so I go to Andre and I say can the kids
are yeah sure boss so we so one day he's
working when I'm not working the scene
where he rescues Mandy the indigo
from he's in the Brew he's the brute
Squad right and uh I we go to his
trailer his trailer is as big as a
boxcar because he couldn't get into the
makeup trailer and he's sitting down at
the end right and I'm holding one of my
kids and my ex-wife is holding the other
and we walk up the steps and turn the
corner and we look down the length of
the the makeup trailer and Andre gets up
and suddenly the reality hits my girls
and they start screaming at the top of
their lungs
[Music]
so you know high-pitched thing that
little girls can do that can shatter
your nerves they and they wouldn't stop
and so I take them away and I go back to
apologize to Andre and I say Andre Andre
I'm so sorry and he said don't worry
boss they either run to me or they'll
run away from me
and that was his experience because he
was the most famous person in the world
almost yeah